THIS IS OUR FIRST HEARING AND A
SERIES OF SIX HEARINGS THAT WE
WILL HOLD FOR ASSEMBLY BILLS WE
HAVE THIRTY BILLS ON TODAY'S
AGENDA BUT DO NOT BE AFRAID --
MANY OF THEM ARE ON CONSENT.
AB SEVEN OH THREE BY DOCTOR
WEBER HAS BEEN PULLED OVER BY
THE COMMITTEE FOR FURTHER
CONSIDERATION.
AB SEVEN TEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CERVANTES HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR AND WE HAVE NINETEEN
ITEMS ON CONSENT WILL BE
LIMITING TESTIMONY TO TWO PEOPLE
PER SIDE AND TWO MINUTES PER
PERSON.
OTHER WITNESSES MAY STATE THEIR
NAME ORGANIZATION AB POSITION
AND NO OTHER TESTIMONY WILL BE
LOUD.
WE DO NOT HAVE A QUORUM SO WE
WILL START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
AND I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MEDINA
COMMON FORWARD PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING SIR
.
BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
BUT TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AB
FIVE FOURTEEN WHICH WOULD CREATE
A STEP.
ENABLING A NEW STUDENT CHRISTY.
TO BE A FULLY EMPOWERED VOTING
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
BEGINNING ON THEIR FIRST YEAR OF
APPOINTMENT.
IN THE TIME BETWEEN NINETEEN
SEVENTY FIVE AND NINETEEN NINETY
NINE THE STUDENT POPULATION HAS
GROWN TO OVER.
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOUBLING
THE STUDENT POPULATION IN THE
CALENDAR STATE A CALIFORNIA.
STATE UNIVERSITY.
THE STUDENT POPULATION IS MUCH
MORE DIVERSE NOW AND THAT
DIVERSITY REQUIRES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE DIFFERENT
PERSPECTIVES PRESENTED THROUGH
THE VOTE OF THE TRUSTEES.
THE STUDENT TRUSTEE EXERCISES A
CRUCIAL ROLE OF REPRESENTING ALL
STUDENTS ON THE CSU BOARD OF
TRUSTEES.
AB FIVE FOURTEEN IS SIMPLE AND
REASONABLE STEP THAT SEEKS TO
RATIONALLY INCREASE THE POWER OF
THE STUDENT VOICE ON THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES.
WITH ME TODAY IS ONE GARCIA.
IS STARTING HIS SECOND YEAR AS A
STUDENT BOARD OF TRUSTEE.
WILL BE THE INCOMING VOTING
STUDENT.
ALSO MY YOU'RE GOOD AT ALL --
EXPECTING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A QUORUM I WILL
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR WELCOME
PLEASE PROCEED.
THE MORNING COMMUTER LEYVA AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS ONE GARCIA
I'M A STUDENT AT CAL POLY POMONA
AND THE CURRENT NONVOTING SU
INTEREST THE FOR THE CSU WERE
CHRISTIE'S AT LEAST FOR A FEW
MORE WEEKS.
I'M THANKFUL TO THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AS WELL AS THE KELSEY
SINICIZATION FOR THEIR
LEADERSHIP IN OFFERING AB.
FIVE FOURTEEN AS YOU ALL KNOW
THE CSU BOARD OF TRUSTEES OF THE
CRITICAL BODY FOR ISSUES RELATED
TO STUDENTS SHE'S LIKE TUITION
CURRICULUM ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
ALL FALL UNDER THE PURVIEW OF
THE BOARD.
THIS IS WHY HAVING ADEQUATE
STUDENT REPRESENTATION ON THE
BOARD IS VITALLY IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE STUDENT VOICES ARE TRULY
CONSIDERED AND CAN INFLUENCE
THESE IMPORTANT DISCUSSIONS.
CURRENTLY WHILE THERE ARE TWO
STUDENT TRUSTEES ONLY ONE CAN
VOTE.
THIS PAST YEAR AS THE NONVOTING
CENTRICITY I ATTENDED ALL BOARD
MEETINGS AND FUNCTIONS AS WELL
AS ALL CSSA BOARD MEETINGS.
AND WORKED AS HARD AS I COULD TO
REPRESENT THE STUDENT VOICE.
HOWEVER.
WHEN IT CAME TO FUNCTIONALLY
INFLUENCING THESE IMPORTANT
POLICY CONVERSATIONS?
I WAS NOT ABLE TO VOTE.
AS AN EXAMPLE THIS YEAR I WAS
ONE OF ONLY A HANDFUL OF BOARD
MEMBERS WHO ATTENDED ALL CSU
PRESIDENTIAL HIRING MEETINGS FOR
POSITIONS I CAST A HUMBLED.
SAN FRANCISCO STATE HEALTHY SAN
MARCUS AND CAL STATE FULLERTON
LETME TELL YOU SOME OF THOSE
WERE FOURTEEN HOUR DAYS.
THIS IS A PROBLEM THAT AB FIVE
FOURTEEN WILL FIX AS A REALLY
BRIEF HISTORICAL REFERENCE AND
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED
CSU STUDENTS ADVOCATED IN THE
SEVENTIES OR REPRESENTATION ON
THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
THEY RECEIVED THROUGH STATE
LEGISLATION IS THE INTERESTING.
THE NEXT TWENTY FIVE YEARS
STUDENTS AT ONE VOICE AND ONE
VOTE ON THE BOARD.
IN THE LATE NINETIES STUDENT
LEADERS ADVOCATED FOR THE NEED
FOR MORE REPRESENTATION ON THE
BOARD.
THE SURVIVALIST IN A DOUBLE
BECOME MORE DIVERSE WITH NEW
CAMPUS IS OPENING. TWO
INDIVIDUALS WASN'T ONE WITH --
AND ONE WITHOUT A VOTE FOR THE
NECESSARY BY THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR TO REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
STUDENTS [inaudible]
NOW.
THE CITY POPULATION HAS GROWN BY
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
STUDENTS AND IT'S FAIRLY NEW
CAMPUS AT CSU CHANNEL ISLANDS
HAS BEEN OPENED AND OUR STUDENT
POPULATION IS INCREDIBLY MORE
DIVERSE.
IT'S AN ASSEMBLY VEST WITHIN THE
SECOND STUDENTS ALL THE RIGHTS
PRIVILEGES AND RESPONSIBILITIES
GIVEN TO ALL OTHER BOARD MEMBERS
AND IN PARTICULAR THE RIGH TO
VOTE.
ADDITIONALLY I WOULD KNOW THE
STUDENTS ARE IN A UNIQUE
OPPORTUNITY UNAVAILABLE TO ANY
OTHER GROUP TO MAKE THIS
IMPORTANT GAME.
SIMPLY GIVING THE NON VOTING
TRUSTEE THE ABILITY TO VOTE DOES
NOT CHANGE THE STATE
APPOINTMENTS PROCESS WOULD
REQUIRE NO NEW FUNDS TO THE
STATE.
AS I MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY EVEN
THOUGH I AM THE NONVOTING
TRISTEN I'VE ATTENDED LIKEALL
MY PREDECESSORS ALL BOARD
MEETINGS AND FUNCTIONS AND I'VE
WORKED HARD TO UNDERSTAND THIS
IN PERSPECTIVE.
ON ISSUES AND BE A FAIR AND
ACCURATE REPRESENTATIVE ON THE
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB FIVE
FOURTEEN FUTURE STUDENTS IN MY
SITUATION WILL SIMPLY BE ABLE TO
VOTE ON THIS MATTER.
AND LASTLY I WOULD NOTE THAT OUR
FRIENDS IN THE CSU STATE WHY I
CAN BE SENATE AS WELL AS BE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION.
SUPPORT THIS BILL AS PRESENTED
AS THE RESPECT THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL AGENCY FOR STUDENTS
AT THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES.
AB FIVE FOURTEEN REPRESENTS A
MODEST AND LOGICAL NEXT STEP TO
STUDENT REPRESENTATION ANSWERED
GOVERNANCE WITHIN THE CSE.
WE BELIEVE IT IS TIME TO TRULY
RESPECT AND HONOR THE SENATE
LEADERS WHO TAKE ON THIS GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY AND ALLOW THEM TO
REPRESENT HOLY THE NEARLY HALF A
MILLION STUDENTS IN THE CSU.
SO WE HOPE YOU CAN SUPPORT FOR
STUDENTS AND SUPPORT AB.
FIVE FORTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD JOB ON THOSE LONG DAYS AND
LISTENING AND BEING AN ACTIVE
PARTICIPANT.
WE'RE GONNA STOP FOR A QUICK
SECOND WE HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO AND TAKE THE ROLE.
AND ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
LEAVE THEM.
HERE LEYVA HERE WILK PRESIDENT
WELL CARE CHIANG RUSSELL.
RUSSELL HERE GLAZER GLAZER HERE
MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN HERE.
I'M SENATOR PAM.
ALRIGHT VERY GOOD PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING CHARLIE BY MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- MARIO
GUERRERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WANT TO START BY THINKING
ASSEMBLY MMBER MEDINA FOR
OFFERING THIS BILL ON BEHALF OF
OUR TWENTY NINE NINE THOUSAND
FACULTY -- INCLUDING TENURE
TRACK PROFESSORS LECTURES
LIBRARIANS -- AND COACHES FROM
ALL OVER TWENTY THREE CAMPUSES
IN THE CSU SYSTEM WE ARE HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB -- FIVE FOURTEEN
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL FOR VERY
SIMPLE REASONS ONE THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO STRENGTHEN THE VOICES
OF STUDENTS ON THE CSU BOARD --
WE SUPPORT TO SUFFER TO FURTHER
ENGAGE STUDENTS IN THE CITY AS
USE OUR DECISION MAKING PROCESS --
AND WE SUPPORT THE SEPARATE
BECAUSE WE NEED MORE ADVOCATES
IN AN INSTITUTION THAT PLAYS AN
OUTSIZE ROLE -- FOR SO MANY WITH
REGARDS TO UPWARD MOBILITY -- WE
RESPECTFULLY URGE THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT FOR A BI FIVE FOURTEEN
AS WRITTEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH TO OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING ONE OF THE AS MY
VALLEY KINCAID WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THING THEN IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS YESTERDAY.
THANK YOU CHARLIE FIVE FIRST BY
I DO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I
APPRECIATE -- NO AND INCREASING
THE STUDENT VOICE FOURTH -- I DO
I SHOULD MAKE MENTION THOSE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THIS BILL IS THAT
PERHAPS WE SHOULD LOOK AT THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE OF THE BOARD
AND YACHT PREVIOUSLY CARRY
LEGISLATION
SO THAT ACTUALLY THE STAFF --
WOULD ACTUALLY HAVE A MEMBER ON
THE BOARD THAT BRINGS THAT
PERSPECTIVE BECAUSE WE KNOW THE
US ONLY TO STUDENTS ARE THE ONES
BEING TAUGHT FACULTY HAVE A YARD
TEACHERS AND EDUCATORS AND HE
ROLE THERE BUT STAFF TO ACTUALLY
SUPPORT.
THE ACTIVITIES AS WELL I KNOW
THAT'S NOT FAR THIS BILL NOT
ASKING THAT BE PART OF THE BUT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO RAISE
THIS IN THE CONVERSATION ABOUT
REPRESENTATION ON THE BOARD AND
WHAT.
OF VOICES ARE ON THE BOARD SO --
SO I DO SUPPORT THE BILL BE
HAPPY TO MOVE AT THE PROTOTYPE
BY HOPE AT SOME POINT WE CAN
HOUSE -- HAVE A CONVERSATION I
KNOW GOVERNOR BROWN WAS NOT SO
FAVOURABLE BUT WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF THE
OVERALL BOARD ANDTHERE ARE
OTHER VOICES THAT SHOULD BE
THEIR DEBT -- THAT THIRTEEN
POINT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN -- NO FOR
THE YES DOCTOR CENTER GLAZER
DOCTOR.
DOCTOR BUT NOW I'M NOT.
THERE'S A LOT OF WISDOM COMING
FROM THE OTHER SIDE OF THE TABLE --
BUT YEAH I HAVE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE IN THE SPACE --
SERVING FOUR YEARS ON THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES AND I CAN SPEAK.
TO THE WONDERFUL AND VALUED ROLE
THAT STUDENT TRUSTEES HAVE
PLAYED -- THROUGHOUT.
MY YEARS OF SERVICE -- BOTH THAT
THE VOTING MEMBER AND THE THE
NON VOTING NUMBER I GUESS IS
THAT THAT THE TERM THAT'S USED --
AND I I DO KNOW THAT AND I
CONCUR WITH WHAT THE SENATOR
PANS COMMENTS ABOUT THE THE
OVERALL PICTURE -- BECAUSE I
KNOW WE HAVE FACED PRESSURES IN
THE PAST TO ADD A FACULTY MEMBER
AT A STAFF MEMBER.
WHY NOT HAVE A SECOND ALUMNI
TRUSTEE -- AND SO I KNOW THAT IT
TO IN THE BROADER CONTEXT ARE WE
JUST PICKING A SPOT BUT I DO
THINK THAT -- THE STUDENTS ARE
WHY WE'RE HERE -- WHY WE DO WHAT
WE DO?
AND AND I THINK THAT -- IT'S A
IT'S A IT'S AN IMPORTANT MESSAGE
TO SEND -- TO THE TRUSTEES AND
EVERYONE THAT THE STUDENTS VOICE
IS VERY VALUED AND AND WE SHOULD
LOOK FOR EVERY POSSIBLE AVENUE.
I'M NOT JUST ON THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES BUT EVERYTHING SYSTEM
DOES TO INCLUDING CORPORATE
STUDENT VOICE.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER ANY
OTHER COMMENTS OR CONCERNS.
I TENEMENT A SENATOR MEDINA I
DEFINITELY MORE CAFFEINE IN THIS
MORNING.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO I I JUST WANT -- TO AGREED
WITH DOCTOR PAD THAT THAT
CERTAINLY THE IT IS WORTH TAKING
A LOOK AT THE TOTAL COMPOSITION.
OF THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES -- THAT
IS PROBABLY -- TIME TO DO THAT --
BUT AT AT AND AT THE SAME TIME
JUST THANK HE STUDENTS FOR ALL
THEIR EFFORTS IN PUTTING THIS
BILL FORWARD.
AND AND AGREE WITH THE SENATOR
GLAZER THAT CERTAINLY THE
STUDENTS VOICE NEEDS TO BE --
VERY MUCH LISTEN TO SPECIALLY
GIVEN HOW MUCH COLLEGE IT'S
CHANGE.
IN IN THE IN THE IN THE LASTFEW
YEARS AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEMBERSHIP WITH THE AND MOVED IN
YEAH.
ITEM SEVEN AB ONE FIVE FOR THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
FLOOR LEYVA BY LEYVA AYE WILK
AYE WILK AYE CHAIN WRESTLE.
WITH US ALL AYE GLAZER GLAZER
AYE MCGUIRE HAN HI CAN I ALL
RIGHT THAT BILL IS OUT WE'LL
WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR US
SENATOR MCGUIRE TO VOTE.
YOU HAVE THREE MORE BILLS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DO I JUST GO IN
AND NUMERICAL ORDER -- IF I
COULD -- AB FIVE NINE FIVE NINE
FIVE THAT WOULD BE JUST FINE.
TO PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
RIGHT AB FIVE NINE FIVE WOULD
CREATE A PATH TO ALLOW
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS TO ENTER
ALLIED HEALTH.
AND OTHER APPRENTICESHIP AN
INTERNSHIP TRAINING PROGRAMS
WITHOUT HAVING TO ENROLL IN THE
DOCK A PROGRAM.
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OFFER A WIDE ARRAY OF PROGRAMS
THAT REQUIRE PARTICIPATION IN AN
APPRENTICESHIP FOR INTERNSHIP
PROGRAM.
HOWEVER MANY OF THOSE PROGRAMS
REQUIRE STUDENTS TO HAVE A VALID
SOCIAL SECURITY.
NUMBER.
WHICH PREVENTS UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FROM
FOR DHAKA FROM ENTERING THESE
PROGRAMS. FOR YOU COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRANCERS OFFICE
ESTIMATES THAT UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS MAKE UP FIFTY TO
SEVENTY THOUSAND OF THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE POPULATION.
THE SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBER
REQUIREMENT ISN'T IT POSSIBLE
OBSTACLE FOR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
DOCTOR.
THE IRS ISSUES INDIVIDUAL TAX
IDENTIFICATION NUMBERS TO
INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE THE US
TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBER
BUT DO NOT HAVE AN ARE NOT
ELIGIBLE? FOR SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER.
HI T. I. N..
ARE NOT AN IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT TOOL.
AND NOT SHARING APPLICANTS
PRIVATE INFORMATION.
IS NECESSARY FOR ENSURING TAX
COMPLIANCE.
AB FIVE NINETY FIVE WOULD ALLOW
USING THE INDIVIDUAL I. T. I.
AND IN LIEU OF A SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. FOR THOSE STUDENTS WHO
DON'T HAVE.
ONE WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT.
IS RENEE LOZANO TRANSFERRED
COORDINATOR FOR EL CAMINO
COLLEGE.
AND CHRISTOPHER SANCHEZ POLICY
ADVOCATE FOR THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS.
VERY GOOD PLEASE PROCEED TO HAVE%
TWO MINUTES A GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE I TURN LEYVA AND
ESTEEM -- COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ONE OF THOSE I DON'T
LIKE -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA
HAD JUST MENTIONED -- I'M STILL
GETTING USED TO THE DOCTOR AND I
RECENTLY GOT MY DEGREE IN -- IN
EDUCATIONAL LEADERSHIP AND I
MENTION THAT BECAUSE MY TOPIC
WAS IMMIGRANT MALE LATINOS IN
THE COMMITTEE COLLEAGUES.
COLLEGES BEING THAT IT'S SUCH AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE.
NOT ONLY BECAUSE I AM A CHANCE
ON A CORNER AND MY COLLEGE BUT
ALSO BECAUSE I AM THE ADVISER OF
THE A DOCUMENT SETTING A
REALIZATION ON CAMPUS SO.
I SEE MYSELF AS AN ADVOCATE IN.
MY SETTING -- I BELIEVE THAT AS
COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO HAVE ACCESS
BUT TO ENGAGE OUR STUDENTS IN A
REAL WAY AND FOR ME THIS BILL.
I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE CALL JUST
TO SUPPORT A. B..
FIVE NINETY FIVE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT IT'S AN ABSOLUTE IMPORTANT
BILL.
DIED BEYOND ACCESS ALLOWS OUR
STUDENTS.
TO ENGAGE IN PROGRAMS THAT
REQUIRE A PRINT AND SHIP OR
INTERNSHIP PROGRAM SUCH AS THE
KOREAN TECHNICAL EDUCATION
PROGRAMS ALLIED HEALTH.
AND OF COURSE QUE TO TALK
TEACHING TO NAME A FEW -- I WAS
A NURSING COUNSEL WHEN I FIRST
BEGAN MY CAREER AND I SOLVE PRE
DHAKA THE EFFECT THAT NOT HAVING
THIS BILL HAD ON STUDENTS DREAMS.
AND QUITE HONESTLY WE IN
CALIFORNIA REAL GOOD AT CREATING
OUR OWN.
A GROWING OUR OWN SORT OF
TALENTED STUDENTS AND I THINK
IT'S A SHAME TO NOT BE ABLE TO
HAVE THEM.
ENGAGE IN THE PROGRAMS THAT THEY
CARE ABOUT AND THAT THEY WOULD
BE REALLY PASSIONATE ABOUT.
AND LET'S BE HONEST TO REPRESENT
THEM IN THE COMMUNITIES OF THE
CORRUPTION I THINK THAT WOULD BE
A SHAME FOR CALIFORNIA NOT TO BE
ABLE TOALLOW.
OUR OWN STUDENTS THAT WE DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF TIME AND FOR THESE
FIELDS TO TO ENGAGE IN THE SCOTT
CAREERS.
AS YOU KNOW BECAUSE OF DHAKA
BEING ON HOLD AS OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE'RE GOING BACK TO
THOSE DAYS AND I THINK THAT IN
CALIFORNIA I'M VERY PROUD TO BE
A CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGE
EDUCATED WERE ALWAYS AT THE
FOREFRONT.
AND I WANTED TO CONTINUE BEEN AT
THE FOREFRONT BECAUSE I THINK
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT WE NEED
TO BE THAT EXAMPLE.
I THOUGHT THAT I WOULD I WOULD
SAY AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO BE
ABLE -- TO ADVOCATE FOR STUDENTS
IN CALIFORNIA -- OBVIOUSLY THE
HUGE BENEFIT IS THAT THIS FIFTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS THAT ARE IN
OUR SYSTEM -- GET.
TO PURSUE WHATEVER IT ADD CAREER
THEY WANT AND GET BACK TO OUR
OWN COMMUNITIES BY BEING IN THIS
IN THESE FIELDS.
WHICH WITH THAT SO DESPERATELY
NEED LAST TIME I CHECKED WERE
STILL NEED GREAT TEACHERS WE
STILL NEED MORE HEALTH EDUCATORS
YOU KNOW.
AND WE WE WITH THIS IS A GREAT
WAY FOR US TO CONTINUE THAT.
A SLIGHT I'M HERE THIS MORNING
VERY HUMBLE.TO REQUEST AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON AB IN FIVE NINETY FIVE
AND THANK THE COMMITTEE.
FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF CHRIS FOR SCIENCE
WHICH OF THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS AND
STRONG SUPPORTER THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION -- JUST SOME BRIEF
POINTS THAT -- MY COLLEAGUES
MIGHT I'M NOT TOUCHED ON AS
MENTIONED IN THE RECENT IN DHAKA
DOES HAVE AN IMPACT ON
CALIFORNIANS.
IN FACT A RECENT STUDY BY THE
MAJOR POLICY INSTITUTE STATES
THAT ARE ROUGHLY TWENTY SEVEN
DOLLARS AND UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS GRADUATE FROM
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS EVERY
YEAR -- HOWEVER THIS REPORT
DOESN'T SHOULD REFLECT
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS MIGHT HAVE
BEEN PUSHED OUT OF THE SYSTEM
DROPPED OUT OF HIGH SCHOOL ARE
NOT COMPLETE -- IN A TIMELY
MATTER -- BUT WE DO KNOW THAT
THOSE SAME STUDENTS WHO AREN'T
INCLUDED IN THE STUDY -- I WILL
GO TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE MOST
LIKELY EVENTUALLY BECAUSE OF
FEDERAL LEGISLATION REQUIRING --
SOME TYPE OF EDUCATION INCLUDING
TRAINING PROGRAMS APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THAT -- THAT THAT IT
HAS HISTORICALLY BEEN A FEDERAL
POLICY -- AND WE KNOW THAT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ALWAYS BEEN%
ACCESSIBLE FOR OUR FOLKS AND IN
FACT COLLEGES HOW THE MOST
HIGHEST POPULATION OF AB FIVE
FORTY STUDENTS.
SO FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT
AB FIVE AB.
FIVE NINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THOSE IN SUPPORT. SEVEN A GOLDEN
OF THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PROUD SPONSOR OF THIS BILL.
RIVER NOW DIRECTOR OF EDUCATION
FOR THE CATHOLIC CHURCH IN
CALIFORNIA ONE STRONG SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE PROP
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
OUR MANAGER MEMBERS AS ARE THE
OTHER BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO SUPPORT.
BRIAN MACKLIN ABOUT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEAVE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT.
JUSTIN SILICON BACK FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING THAT WILL BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY THE VIEW BILLS
REMOVED IS OR ANY COMMENTS
CONCERNS CENTER GLAZER.
I THANK YOU CHAIR LEYVA I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY
AND I THANK THE AUTHORS FOR THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING IT FORWARD.
FIND CONGRADULATIONS DOCTORS
THINGS NICE TO SAY THAT AND
THAT'S A THAT'S A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK TO GET TO WHERE
YOU ARE SO HE SHOULD RIGHTFULLY
PROUD.
OF BUT I I THINK THIS
LEGISLATION IS VERY CONSISTENT
WITH WHAT WE IN THE SENATE AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAS DONE -- WITH
OTHER STUDENTS IN OUR SYSTEM
DREAMERS.
IN TERMS OF HOW WE'VE HANDLED
FINANCIAL AID AND OTHER THINGS
LIKE THAT AND WELL I KNOW THAT
THERE'D BE AT A GOAL CERTAINLY
OF MINE TO DO MORE -- FOR THOSE
WHO -- REGISTERS I TEND I THINK
THIS IS A PRUDENT AND AFFORDABLE
STEP AND I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT
TODAY.
YOU SENATOR GLAZERS SEEING NO
FURTHER COMMENTS OR QUESTION THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVE.
THIRD RUSSELL.
I TO WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THE AUTHOR AND AND THE
WITNESSES HERE TODAY.
I THINK THIS IS JUST ANOTHER.
STEP IN WHAT SHOULD BE AN
AUTOMATIC WHICH IS THE FULL
INTEGRATION OF ARE UNDOCUMENTED
FAMILIES.
AND YOUTH THE FEDERAL SYSTEM IS
SO BROKEN DOWN TO THINK THAT
EVERY MONTH.
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF GRADUATE
FROM HIGH SCHOOL WE LIVE
TOGETHER WE WORK TOGETHER WE GO
TO SCHOOL TOGETHER WE GO TO
CHURCH TOGETHER -- ALL THESE
THINGS SHOULD JUST BE AN
AUTOMATIC BUT IF WE TAKE IT STEP
BY STEP -- THAT'S A GOOD THING I
HOPE THE DAY WHERE WE CAN JUST.
DO AWAY WITH HAVING TO DO SO
MANY SMALL STEPS AND GET TO THE
FULL INTEGRATION OF EVERYBODY.
BUT WITH THAT SAID I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I THINK THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
ALL RIGHT VERY GOOD.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE -- JUST
TO SAY THAT THIS BILL IS
RECEIVED -- BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YEAR I
VOTE.
THANK YOU SIMPLY MEMBER THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR PAN AM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TEN AB FIVE NINE FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASSED PUBLIC
SAFETY LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE CAME
CHIANG I'D LASSELL WHO WRESTLE
AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE
PAN.
PAN AYE.
BILLS APPROACH TO GET OUT BUT WE
WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR BEING HERE ASSEMBLYMEMBER DO
YOU WANT TO DO SIX NINE FIVE SIX
NINE FIVE YEP.
ALL RIGHT PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AND MEMBERS TO THEIR PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL.
SIX NINE FIVE AB SIX NINE FIVE
EXTENDS THE CURRENT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DESIGN BUILD
STATUES.
UNTIL.
TWENTY THIRTY ACCORDING TO THE
EXPERIENCES FROM COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS THEY USE
DESIGN BUILD CONTRACTING TO
EXPEDIA EIGHT THE CONSTRUCTION.
THE PROJECT AVOID CONFLICTS
BETWEEN ARCHITECTS ENGINEERS AND
CONTRACTORS AND REDUCE COSTS.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THIS IS REBECCA.
EARLY THANK YOU FROM THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACILITY
COALITION.
AND CAESAR DHEAS FROM THE
BUILDING TRADES.
VERY GOOD PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY.
GOOD MORNING REBEKAH CURLY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACILITY COALITION IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL A DESIGN BUILD
PROCUREMENT PROVIDES A GREAT
TOOL FOR COLLEGES ESPECIALLY ON
LARGE AND COMPLEX PROJECTS.
WE HAVE THE GENERAL AUTHORITY TO
USE THIS METHOD SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVEN SB SIX NINETY
FIVE PROVIDES A TEN YEAR
EXTENSION TO ABOUT OF THE
WARRANTY.
IT'S A COLLABORATIVE APPROACH IT
CAN REDUCE THE RISK OF COST
INCREASES ASSOCIATED WITH CHANGE
ORDERS.
BY ESTABLISHING A GUARANTEED
MAXIMUM PRICE IS THAT'S REDUCING
THE RISK FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT SPECIFICALLY.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE WILLINGNESS
TO WORK THROUGH IMPLEMENTATION
OF SKILLED WORKFORCE PROFESSIONS
WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO ADDRESSING
ANY ISSUES THAT COME UP IN THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT RELATED
TO AVAILABILITY OF SKILLED
WORKERS -- THREE SUPPORTING
THINGS LIKE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
PROCEED MADAM CHAIRMAN RECESS
IDEAS ONLY HALF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL -- PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL THIS LEGISLATION EXTENDS
THE DESIGN BUILD STATURE BUT IT
ALSO INCORPORATES THE IMPORTANT
LABOR PROTECTIONS THAT WERE.
INCLUDED IN PREVIOUS STATUTES
THAT APPLY TO CITIES COUNTIES
STATE AGENCIES ARE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AS WELL AS OTHER
SPECIAL DISTRICTS THOSE ARE OUR
TO INCENTIVIZE THE USE OF
APPRENTICES LIKE THE PREVIOUS
BILL THAT YOU FOR TODAY -- TO
ENSURE THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY
CALIFORNIA WORKERS ARE SKILLED
AND TRAINED TO PERFORM THAT WORK
WE BELIEVE THAT THAT HELP THE
COMMUNITIES ARE WHICH THESE
PROJECTS ARE ACTUALLY INVESTING
IN.
AND SO IT DISTRIBUTES THAT
WEALTH AMONGST THE CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS ARE BILL IN THOSE
PROJECTS AND DESIGN BUILD IN AND
OF ITSELF DOES NOT SACRIFICE A
LABOR PROTECTIONS WHEN IT HAS A
SKILLED AND TRAINED FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MARK MCDONALD
MCCALLUM GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE
KERN FOOTHILL DE ANZA PERALTA.
SAN BERNADINO AND SAN DIEGO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS THAT
HAVE HAD -- SUCCESS WITH
UTILIZING THIS -- TYPE OF OF
PRODUCT PROJECT DELIVERY.
WHEN YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU?
JUSTIN SILICON AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCES OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORT
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU THING THAT
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
CENTER WELCOME THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS A GREAT BILLS OF
FORMER COMMUNITY COLLEGE BORDER
TRUSTEE. ONE OF THE WORST THING
HE EVER HEARS CHANGE ORDER.
AND AFTER FAR TOO OFTEN IN FACT --
WHEN THE LAW WAS CHANGED --
MIGHT.
BECAUSE DISTRICTS SEPARATE
COMMUNICATIONS SERVICE AS WHEN
THE FIRST ONES TO DO IDEA SAY --
DESIGN BUILD PROGRAM LIKE THIS
AND WE SAVE SO MUCH MONEY WE ARE
ACTUALLY ABLE TO TO DO. TO
ESCALATE OUR SCHEDULING BILL TO
BUILD A SECOND FACILITY SO THIS
IS WORKING VERY WELL AND HAS ALL
THE PROTECTIONS OF MY FRIEND
SAYS OUR NEEDS.
SO I WANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE TODAY.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE JUST TO SAY THAT IS --
COMMUNING CONSTRUCTS THE FOR
THIRTEEN YEARS I SAW A LOT OF
CHANGE ORDERS AND I'M GLAD TO BE
MOVING THIS BILL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE VERY GOOD THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
CHIANG.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWELVE AB SIX NINETY FIVE
THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL HI WILK I CHIANG
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER PLEASE ARE
AYE MCGUIRE PAN.
PAN AYE.
GOOD THE BILL HAS ENOUGH VOTES
TO GET OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
ON CALL.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLYMEMBER MEDINA
YOU HAVE ONE MORE BILL BEFORE US
AB TEN NINETY TWO MORE.
THE OTHER. ONE FIFTEEN FORD
FOCUS ON THE NEXT PAGE WELL
WE'RE JUST HAPPY TO HAVE YOU
SPENDING SO MUCH TIME WITH US
TODAY.
GO TO TEN NINETY FOUR SEE
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY SO AB TEND
IT WITH A MAN THE ALLEN PADDY
SCHOLARSHIP ACT.
OF NINETEEN SEVENTY WHICH WAS
CREATED. TO ASSIST SURVIVING
FAMILY MEMBERS OF FIREFIGHTERS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS WHO
DIED IN THE LINE OF DUTY.
AB TEND IT WILL EXPAND THE
EXISTING EXEMPTION FROM
MANDATORY SYSTEM WHY TUITION AND
FEES.
AT UC HASTINGS CSU AND THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM. TO ACCEPT THESE ALIBIED
ELIGIBLE SURVIVORS FROM
MANDATORY CAMPUS BASED FEES.
THESE CAMPUS BASED FEES ARE
APPROVED AT THE CAMPUS LEVEL AND
VERY AMONG THE CAMPUSES AND CAN
RANGE UP TO THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
AS WE ALL KNOW HIGHER EDUCATION
IS EXPENSIVE.
THE FORTY NINE OF FOURTEEN A
COLLEGE EDUCATION CAN BE
BURDENSOME RELYING ON JUST ONE
INCOME.
AB TEN NINETY WILL HAVE FREE OF
COST PUBLIC COLLEGE OR
UNIVERSITY ELIMINATING ANY CLASS
BARRIERS FOR SURVIVING FAMILY
MEMBERS OF FIREFIGHTERS AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
OFFICERS HAVE DIED IN THE LINE
OF DUTY.
WITH MADE SUPPORT IS DAVE JULY
RD PRESIDENT OF THE LA COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS LOCAL.
TEN FOURTEEN LORI WAS SO GO.
A SURVIVING SPOUSE OF FALLEN LA
COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WELCOME TO BOTH
OF YOU.
GOOD MORNING YOU'RE READY MY
NAME'S DAVE GELATI AND I'M NOT
ONLY THE PRESIDENT OF THE LA
COUNTY FIREFIGHTERS.
BUT I'M AN ACTIVE DUTY FIRE
CAPTAIN IN SOUTH CENTRAL LOS
ANGELES WAS SPENT SO THE BETTER
PART OF MY THIRTY ONE YEARS
SERVING AND LOW INCOME DISTRICTS.
AND I'VE SEEN MY FAIR SHARE OF
TRAGEDY WITH FALLEN FIREFIGHTERS
IN LA COUNTY.
I ALSO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF BRIAN
RICE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THE
THIRTY THOUSAND FIVE OR
STATEWIDE.
AND FRANKLY MY FROM THE I FF
TENTH DISTRICT REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S FIREFIGHTERS WE
HAVE THIRTY TWO HUNDRED MEN AND
WOMEN SERVING IN LA COUNTY.
WITH THAT I JUST WANT YOU TO
KNOW IT'S A VERY SMALL
POPULATION THAT WE'RE DEALING
WITH HERE IT'S AN ALUMNI YOU
HOPE NOT TO BE A PART OF BUT I'M
SO PROUD TO INTRODUCE FOR YOU A
STRONG SISTER.
THE WIFE OF CAPTAIN JOHN MASAKO
WHO PASSED ON OUR JOB AND SHE'S
HERE TO GIVE A FACE AND A
PICTURE TO WHAT THIS BILL WILL
DO FOR OUR FAMILIES AND OUR CHEN
AYE VOTE.
LAURIE MASAKO.
HE WAS JULY PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS LAURIE MASAKO CREWS MY
HUSBAND JOHN MASAKO WAS A FIRE
CAPTAIN FOR THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT WHERE HE
PROUDLY SERVE FOR TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS.
HE DIED IN THE LINE OF DUTY ON
DECEMBER TWELFTH TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN AFTER PAINFUL IN
EXCRUCIATING BATTLE WITH JOB
CAUSE CANCER HE WAS ONLY FORTY
EIGHT YEARS OLD.
AS YOU WOULD EXPECT JOHN HANDLED --
HIS ILLNESS THE WAY HE HANDLED
HIS JOB AS A FIREFIGHTER WITH
COURAGE AND DETERMINATION.
LIKE MANY PARENTS HIS GREATEST
DESIRE WAS TO SEE OUR SONS
MATTHEW AND MICHAEL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO COLLEGE.
HIS -- UNTIMELY DEATH IN HER
ROOM LOOKED AT CREATE AN OBVIOUS
HARDSHIP FOR OUR FAMILY.
BUT WE ARE COMFORTED TO KNOW
THAT THE STATE WOULD HONOR HIS
SURFACE SERVICE AND SACRIFICE BY
FOURTEEN OR SENDS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND PUBLIC
COLLEGE IN CALIFORNIA.
THROUGH THE SURVIVOR TUITION
WAIVER.
THAT OF COURSE ENDED UP NOT
BEING TRUE IN OUR CASE.
I CAME BEFORE YOU A FEW YEARS
AGO EXPLAINING THAT ONE OF MY
SONS MATTHEW WAS DENIED THE
WAIVER DUE TO AN AMBIGUITY IN
THE LAW.
THE HOUSE STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUS CHICO STATE.
THAT OUR SON PLANTED TEN WOULD
ACCEPT JOB RELATED CANCER IS A
LINE OF DUTY DEATH.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE A STRANGER
TELLING ME THAT MY HUSBAND
SACRIFICE WAS FOR NOT WAS
DEMEANING AND GUT WRENCHING.
THANKS TO YOUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR BROWN
THIS INJUSTICE HAS BEEN REMEDIED.
SO MY FAMILY DIDN'T DIRECTLY
BENEFIT I'M HAPPY THAT OTHER
FAMILIES DON'T HAVE TO SHARE MY
EXPERIENCE.
BUT I AM SURPRISED TO FIND
MYSELF BACK HERE IN SACRAMENTO
TALKING ABOUT HIGHER EDUCATION
SURVIVING FAMILIES IN THE BURN
THEY FACE WITH A COST.
I THOUGHT WE PUT THIS ISSUE TO
REST.
BUT CAMPUS FEES ARE NOT COVERED
BY THIS SURVIVOR TUITION WAIVER
AND THESE FEES CAN BE X. ORDER.
THEY CAN BE UP TO THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS A YEAR THAT MUST BE PAID
OUT OF POCKET AND I CAN TELL YOU
FROM EXPERIENCE THAT THE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIP.
A SURVIVING FAMILY FACES IS
DAUNTING WHAT ONCE WAS A SOLID
MIDDLE CLASS LIKE CAN CERTAINLY
BE ON VERY SHAKY GROUND.
AND YOUR GRIEF IS AMPLIFIED BY
THE WORRY OF YOUR FAMILY'S
FINANCIAL FUTURE.
I URGE ALL OF YOU TO ALLEVIATE
THE BURDEN SURVIVING FAMILIES
FACE AN HONOR THE SACRIFICE OF
OUR FALLEN FIREFIGHTERS AND
POLICE OFFICERS.
PLEASE PASS AB TEN NINETY AND
FULLY SUPPORT THE PURSUIT OF
HIGHER EDUCATION A SURVIVING
CHILDREN IN OUR SPOUSES THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
FOR SHARING YOUR STORY AND
COMING BACK TO FIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. SEVEN A
GOLDEN OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
WHAT ELSE AND?
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THING THEN WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
DR PAM.
SO I UNDERSTAND THIS BILL A
REDUCE THE FEES THE ISSUE THAT
LED TO THE DECISION BUT SHE GOT
A SEVEN CLARIFIED OR NOT I PAID
HIS TUITION I AM THE ONLY.
FAMILY THAT HAS US ALWAYS TO
THAT STONE OUTSTANDING PROBLEM
THEN NO IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
RESOLVED WE PURSUED IT AND WE
PROCEEDED ADMINISTRATIVELY
LEGALLY AND WE WERE NOT ABLE TO
RECOVER THE FOR OKAY.
BUT WE HAVE ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR HEY KRISTI BALLOT BE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS.
THEY'VE SPOKEN ARE WE HAVE BUT
WE DID ACTUALLY DO A BILL A TO
CLARIFY THAT PIECE FOR A FOR
SURVIVING FAMILY MEMBERS WHO'S.
A FIREFIGHTER PEACE OFFICER DIED
IN THE LINE OF DUTY AND IN NON IT DUE TO A JOB RELATED
ILLNESS SO THAT HAS BEEN
CLARIFIED AND THE OKAY AND ANGST
TO ALL OF YOU THANK YOU.
THE NATIONALTHEATRET IT WAS JUST
IT HAPPENED AFTER IT HAPPENED.
I'M SORRY.
THE ONLY ONE AFFECTED BY I JUST
WANT TO I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY
THAT WE ACTUALLY THAT BUT I
REALIZE IT DIDN'T ADDRESS A FOR
YOU PERSONALLY BUT RIGHT NOW
MOVING FORWARD AS A RATE ADDRESS
STATUS BECAUSE THAT'S A SEPARATE
OKAY.
FEES OR ANYTHING RIGHT OKAY
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
FOR THE CLARIFICATION THE BILL
HAS BEEN MOVED WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
BOTH THE WITNESSES AGAIN. FOR
BEING HERE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE BOOK.
THANK YOU SOMEONE MEMBER THE
BILL HAS BEEN MOVED BY SENATOR
GLAZER MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWENTY THREE AB TEN NINETY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK AYE WILK AYE
CHANGE CHIANG I'D RUSSELL
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN HI CAN I THE BILL
HAS ENOUGH VOTES TO GET OUT BUT
WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WELCOME AGAIN
THANK YOU ALRIGHT ARE YOU READY
2% FIFTEEN OH FOUR I'M READY ALL
RIGHT LET'S DO IT IN GOOD TO BE
HERE.
PROCEED WITH A I'D LIKE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL.
FIFTEEN OH FOUR I WILL START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TO THE BILL.
THE CLICK CLARIFY THE OPT OUT
PROVISIONS.
DUE TO LACK OF RESOURCES THE
STUDENT SENATE OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAS VIRTUALLY
NO PRESENCE IN THE STATE CAPITOL.
IN LITTLE TO NO ABILITY TO
ADVOCATE FOR LEGISLATION THAT
AFFECTS CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
SO AS CSU STUDENTS AND USE THE
STUDENTS ARE ABLE.
TO COME HERE AND EXPRESS THEIR
CONCERNS.
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS DON'T
HAVE THAT SAME ABILITY.
AB FIFTY NO FOUR WOULD ENSURE
THAT A TWO DOLLAR STUDENT
REPRESENTED.
REPRESENTATION FEE IS
IMPLEMENTED AT ALL CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BY COLLECTED
IT FROM ALL STUDENTS UPON
PAYMENT A REGISTRATION FEES.
THIS BILL WILL HELP ENSURE THAT
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS HAVE
AN EQUAL VOICE WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICIES AND LEGISLATION THAT
IMPACT THEM.
AND I'D LIKE TO MAKE IT CLEAR
THAT IS A STUDENTS WHO BROUGHT
FORTH THIS IDEA.
WITH ME TODAY IS.
I ASIA YOUNGBLOOD PRESIDENT OF
THE STUDENT SENATE OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU SIR SIR WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME CHAIR
COMMITTEE -- YES I'D JUST LIKE
TO ECHO WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA SAID THE STUDENT SENATE.
HISTORICALLY HASN'T HAD VERY
MUCH PRESENCE IN THE CAPITAL AND
THEN ACTING THIS.
WOULD ALLOW US NOT ONLY TO HAVE
PROFESSIONAL STAFF BUT ACTUALLY
BE A VOICE FOR THE TWO POINT ONE
MILLION STUDENTS THAT WE
REPRESENT.
AND SO I WOULD JUST LIKE AN AYE
VOTE.
EXCELLENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL SEE IF
WE CAN HELP YOU OUT ON THAT.
BUT IS THERE ANYONE IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING STEPHANIE GOLDEN ON
BEHALF THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
IN SUPPORT.
MORNING ONE OF THE AS MY VALLEY
IN KATE WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT I WOULD ALSO IF I MAY --
LIKE TO MENTION THAT WE
SUBMITTED A LETTER ALONG WITH
PARTNERS I'M AT TRUST WEST THE
UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION.
THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS.
AND THE LETTER AND THE PARTNERS
WERE NOT REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS OR ON THE SENATE --
AGENDA AND SO I'D JUST LIKE TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT WAS NOTED
I'M AND I HAVE COPIES OF THE
LETTER IF YOU LIKE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MANAGER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNICATIVE CHANCES
OFFICE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THE MORNING A HANNAH BRAG START
WITH THE CAL STATE STUDENT
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL COME ON DOWN. FOR A LITTLE
LATE MANY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE EDUCATION TRUST WEST HERE IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
SEEM TO OPPOSITION WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
COMMENTS CENTER GLAZER -- I ASIA
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE IT'S
NOT EASY TO GO TO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND BE A GREAT ADVOCATE
HERE IN THE CAPITAL SO WITH FOR
SHAPE THAT EXTRA EFFORT.
I'M SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL TODAY
BUT I DID HAVE SOME QUESTIONS --
IT INDICATES IN THE ANALYSIS OF
ONLY ELEVEN OF THE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN CAMPUSES HAVE FEES NOW.
IS THAT BECAUSE YOU HAVE -- PUT
FEES ON THE BALLOT AND THEY HAVE
FAILED.
SO NO SO THE PROCESS RIGHT NOW
IS LIKE A RIGOROUS -- SO IT HAS
TO BE.
PUT ON THE BALLOT ED EACH ASL
HAS A DIFFERENT.
PROCESS FOR WHAT CAN GO ON A
BALLOT AND IN THAT THEY HAVE TO
BE THE AVERAGE OF THE PAST THREE
ELECTIONS AND HAS THE BEST RATE
WAS SO MOST IS OLDER LIKE THAT'S
TOO MUCH WORK AND SO IT DOESN'T
THEY DON'T BOTHER PUT IT ON IT
BECAUSE I MEAN.
THAT STUDENTS ON TOP OF
SOMETHING ELSE ON TOP OF
SOMETHING ELSE SO A LOT OF A
ESOS JUST DIDN'T GO THROUGH WITH
IT CLARIFIED THAT'S YOU SO
SHOULD STUDENTS.
EACH INDIVIDUAL CHANGE AND I WAS
THE NUMBERS IN THE IN THE IN THE
LETTERS TO CHANGE.
SO I I HAVE TO SAY THAT -- I
FIND THIS A REQUIREMENTS I GUESS
IT'S A STATE REQUIREMENT OF THE
AVERAGE OF THREE ELECTIONS. TO
BE RIDICULOUS.
I MEAN THINK OF WE DID THAT FOR
OUR ELECTIONS OKAY -- IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN THAT SOME WOULD
SAY WAS VERY CONSEQUENTIAL 60%
OF AMERICANS DIDN'T VOTE.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT OUR SENATE
ELECTIONS YESTERDAY.
MY GUESS IS THE TURNOUT IN THOSE
ELECTIONS WOULD NEVER HAVE
PASSED THE REQUIREMENTS THAT
WERE PUTTING ON OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS.
AND SOMEONE A FLAG THAT IS WHAT
I THINK IS AN UNFAIR.
REQUIREMENT TO CREATE A EVEN
GREATER BURDEN ON WHAT YOU WANT
TO ACCOMPLISH IN TERMS OF YOUR
ORGANIZATION OF THE CAMPUSES AND
I HOPE THAT.
WITH THE ESTEEMED AN EXPERIENCE
LEADER ON THIS BILL -- SO
INVOLVED IN THESE ISSUES THAT
PERHAPS WE CAN WORK ON THAT --
IN THE FUTURE BUT I I THINK THIS
IS A GOOD BILL YOU DO PROVIDE AN
OPT OUT FOR STUDENTS AND IT'S A
AND THAT'S THE MAMMOTH THAT THE
STAFF FAST FOR YOU TO ACCEPT AND
I THINK IT'S A GOOD.
ONE BUT I DO THINK THAT YOU
SHOULD BE EMPOWERED TO AND SAID
THESE BARRIERS SHOULD COME DOWN.
AND I'M VERY COMMITTED TO
WORKING WITH YOU TO TRY TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT.
THANK CENTER GLAZER OTHER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
SHE WHEN I THANK THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR TIME THIS MORNING AND
RESPECTFULLY AS FOR YOUR IPHONE
THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THE MOTION BY SENATOR
PAN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM TWENTY NINE AB -- FIFTEEN
FOR THE MOTION IS TO PASSED AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA
LEYVA AYE WILK [inaudible]
CHANGE.
RUSSELL RUSSELL AYE GLAZER
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE.
PAN PAN AYE.
RIGHT THE BILL HAS BEEN OPPOSED
TO GET OUT BUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN WE GOT TO SOME YES VOTES
THANK.
YOU YOU'RE WELCOME.
THANK YOU FOR SPENDING SO MUCH
TIME WITH US ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
MAYBE WE'LL SEE YOU AGAIN IN THE
FUTURE HERE IN THE COMMITTEE.
IT SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU SIR
[inaudible]
WHILE.
SORRY WE ARE HERE IN THE US
SENATE EDUCATION LOOKING FOR
AUTHOR SO IF ANYONE'S LISTENING
COME ON DOWN
.
HE DIDN'T WANT
TO MEMBERS WHILE WAITING FOR AN
AUTHOR WE'RE GOING TO DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR THE ITEMS ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEM ONE
STR EIGHT ITEM THREE AB TWO
THIRTY NINE ITEM FOR A. B..
TWO SEVEN TWO ITEM FIVE AB THREE
EIGHTY ONE ITEM EIGHT AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE ITEM ELEVEN AB.
SIX OH FIVE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
SEVEN FORTY THREE ITEM A
SEVENTEEN AB EIGHT FIFTY THREE
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB.
NINE FORTY SEVEN ITEM TWENTY AB
NINE EIGHTY EIGHT ITEM TWENTY
FOUR A. B..
ELEVEN TWENTY SEVEN CONSENT AS
AMENDED ITEM TWO AB THIRTY FOUR
ITEM NINE AB.
FIVE FORTY THREE ITEM NINETEEN
AB NINE A. B. TWO ITEM TWENTY
ONE AB.
ONE THOUSAND ITEM TWENTY TWO AB
TEN SIXTY TWO ITEM TWENTY SIX AB
TWELVE THIRTY FOUR ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN AB TWELVE FORTY AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST ITEM.
THIRTY AJ ARE TWO MEMBERS IS
THERE ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE TO
REMOVE FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE -- TO HAVE A MOTION
THANK YOU A MOTION MADE B
SENATOR PAN FOR THE CONSECUTIVE --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK HI WILK I CHIANG
CHING I'D RUSSELL.
RUSSELL AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE.
PAN I CAN I WILL LEAVE THAT TIME
ITEM ON OPENED SO I'LL MEMBERS
CAN VOTE I SEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER SO
YOU'RE JONES AND YOUR FIRST UP
IN THE ORDER SO PLEASE COME ON
DOWN.
JOY SO IT IS A THIRD JONES I'M
TELLING YOU ANY MORE HAPPY THIS
MORNING.
MY GOODNESS.
I DON'T LIKE.
YEAH I GOT YEAH.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER
PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR QUITE
WELCOME HIM MEMBERS -- AB FOR
THIRTEEN CHANGES REFERENCES OF
AT RISK TO AT PROMISE IN THE
EDUCATION PENAL CODE.
AT RISK IS A STIGMATIZED LABEL
USED TO DESCRIBE STUDENTS THAT
LIVE IN DIFFICULT SITUATIONS
HAVE CREATED AN EXPECTATION OF
FAILURE.
BY FOCUSING ON THE LIKELIHOOD OF
USED BECOMING ANOTHER STATISTIC.
THIS IS A MINDSET THAT IS ALL
TOO PERVASIVE AND OUR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITIES AS A STATE WE
NEED TO BE MORE AWARE OF THE
MESSAGE THIS LANGUAGE FANS.
AT RISK NOT ONLY INFLUENCES
TEACHERS EXPECTATION BUT ALSO
THE CONFIDENCE OF THOSE STUDENTS
AND HOW MUCH THEY BELIEVE IN
THEMSELVES.
THIS IS A LABEL THAT SHOULD NOT
BE USED TO DESCRIBE THE
POTENTIAL OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
YOUTH [inaudible]
WORDS MATTER.
LET'S BE INTENTIONAL WITHOUT
LANGUAGE AND EMPOWER OUR
STUDENTS IN THE SAME WAY RESPECT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES BY
USING PEOPLE FIRST LANGUAGE.
OUR STUDENTS ARE MORE THAN THEIR
SITUATION AND THEY NEED TO BE
TREATED AS SUCH AB FOUR ONE
THREE TRANSITIONS CALIFORNIA TO
DISTRACT BATES APPROACH OF AT
PROMISE IN RECOGNIZES THE
POTENTIAL OF EVERY USING
CALIFORNIA TO SECEDE.
SENATORS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOAT WITH ME TODAY TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY AS
ERNIE SILVA FROM S..
I. A. TECH AND PAM GIVES THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY THANK
YOU -- CHAIR AND MEMBERS I'M
BERNIE SILVA WITH CYTOTEC WE'RE
OF NETWORK OF SCHOOLS.
I'M AS THEIR OKAY -- NETWORK OF
SCHOOLS THAT RE ENGAGE AT
PROMISE YOUTH -- WE'RE AT THE
SAN BERNADINO JOB CORPS WERE AT
THE SACRAMENTO JOB CORPS -- AND
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED BY WORKING WITH THE
REACHING OUT FROM STUDENTS
ASSOCIATION WITH OTHER.
EDUCATORS FROM ACROSSTHE
COUNTRY IS THAT IS THAT WORDS
MATTER AND THAT AT WROTE AT RISK
HAS.
HAD A DEEP AND NEGATIVE HISTORY
OF WE'VE LOOKED AT WE'VE CALLED
STUDENTS CULTURALLY DEPRIVED IN
DEFICIENT DISADVANTAGED NOW AT
RISK.
THE THIS FOCUSES ON DEFICITS AND
MINIMIZES THE POTENTIAL OF LOW
INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF
COLOR THE FOCUS ON DEFICITS
LOWERS EXPECTATIONS AND LOWERED
EXPECTATIONS LEADS TO FAILURE
AND DISENGAGEMENT.
AT PROMISE FOCUSES ON AN
INDIVIDUAL'S POTENTIAL DR VICTOR
RIO SAID ARE YOU SEE SB LARRY
BELL THEM ALL TO CULTURAL --
AMERICA AND MANY OTHER
ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
ADVOCATE THE USE OF POSITIVE
LABELING STRATEGIES TO GAIN.
DRAMATIC INCREASES IN STUDENT
ACHIEVEMENT.
I'M CHANGING THE DESIGNATION WE
PLACE IN STATUTE FROM AT RISK TO
A PROMISE IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS EQUITY IN EDUCATION.
I AB FOR THIRTEEN SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIA'S WORK AT ADDRESSING
TRAUMA AT BUILDING MEAN OF
MEANINGFUL COMMUNITY
RELATIONSHIPS AND RECOGNIZING
THE CHALLENGES AND VALUES THE
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
WE ASK FOR YOUR I'VE
[inaudible]
VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION.
AS YOU KNOW OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF SCHOOLS
IS A SOCIAL WORKER AND AN
EDUCATOR.
AND PUTS FORWARD AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY THE SOCIAL SOCIAL
AND EMOTIONAL.
WELL BEING OF CHILDREN I WANTED
TO SHARE WITH YOU BRIEFLY AND
EXPERIENCE THAT I HAD A RECENTLY
AS I VOLUNTEERED FOR PROGRAM --
BENEFITING YOUNG GIRLS.
WELL AS YOU KNOW -- AS
IDENTIFIED IN THE ANALYSIS
THERE'S NUMEROUS PROGRAMS THAT
CONSISTED OF THE LANGUAGE AT
RISK MANY OF THESE PROGRAMS WHEN
THEY ARE IN PLACE WE USE FLYERS
OR POSTERS FOR THE EVENTS.
AND OTHERS -- COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND OTHER-ORGANIZATIONS WILL ALSO USE
FLYERS -- AND PUT POSTERS UP A
AT THE EVENTS WHILE I ATTENDED
ONE OF THESE EVENTS AND I WAS
VOLUNTEERING FOR AND I SAW A
POSTER AT THE WELCOMING DOORS
WHERE ALL THE CHILDREN OF
PARTICIPANTS WERE WALKING
TROUGH.
AND THE POSTER SAID IT WAS TO
BENEFIT THE PROGRAM WAS TO
BENEFIT AT RISK YOUTH.
AND I THOUGHT TO MYSELF WELL
WHAT OF THE CHILDREN WHO ARE
HERE WHO STRUGGLED HAVE
CHALLENGING LIVES.
WHO HAVE COME TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROGRAM TO RECEIVE ALL THE
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THAT WE
WERE PROVIDING THEM WHAT WOULD
THAT FEEL LIKE TO THEM?
AND IF WE ONLY CHANGE THE WORDS
TO A PROGRAM BENEFITING AT
PROMISE YOU.
THAT COULD MAKE A BIG DIFFERENCE
SO IT'S NOT JUST A CHANGE IN THE
LAW TO A CHANGE IN HOW WE VIEW
THESE CHILDREN.
AND CHANGING THE CODE FOR ALL OF
THESE PROGRAMS WILL NOT ONLY --
DO THAT BUT IT WILL ALSO IMPACT
THE GOALS AND OBJECTIVES OF EACH
OF THOSE PROGRAMS IDENTIFIED IN
THE ANALYSIS SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY URGE I'VE
FELT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD EXAMPLE
THOSE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JEFF BACA REPRESENTING THE
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS AND I'D SIMPLY
ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THIRTY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY [inaudible]
DR PAM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND I
WANNA THANK YOU SO MEMBER --
CHEN SORT FOR BRING THIS BILL
FORD IS A PEDIATRICIAN ACTUALLY
UC DAVIS -- I TOOK EARLY TUGHT
OUR PEDIATRICIANS OUR FUTURE
PEDIATRICIANS -- ABOUT THEM
PORTS OF TAKING AN ACID BASED
APPROACH INSTEAD OF THIS DEFICIT.
APPROACH RIGHT WE DON'T LOOK AT
OFTEN WE DEFINE PEOPLE BY THEIR
PROBLEMS AFTER ALL THAT'S WHY
THEY COME TO US RIGHT HAVE A
PROBLEM.
AND WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE
STRENGTHS AND THEIR ASSETS AND
WE SPEND A LOT TIME TALKING
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF ASSET
BASED APPROACHES AND I SEE THAT
YOUR BILL IS.
ALONG THE SIDE CERTAINLY IT'S
NOT A PANACEA TO EVERYTHING BUT
HOPEFULLY IT SIGNALS AND THE
IMPORTANT ROLE OF LOOKING AT
EVERYONE.
AS AN ASSET EVERYONE HAS
SOMETHING THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE.
THEY MAY HAVE WATCH CHALLENGES
AND THEY NEED HELP IT DOESN'T
DENY THAT BUT PEOPLE AT
SOMETHING THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE WE
LOOK AT PEOPLE'S CONTRIBUTORS.
IT'S A VERY DIFFERENT LANDS AND
I APPRECIATE THAT THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO AND I MOVED ABOUT
THE PROTOTYPE THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR PAN.
OF WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
MISTER JONES SAWYER YES -- AND I
JUST JUST SIMPLY SAY THAT AND I
JUST.
ONLY BECAUSE THIS IS KIND OF
PERSONAL TO ME MIKE AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW MY UNCLE WAS WHEN THE
LITTLE ROCK NINE ONE AND I KIDS
INTO A CENTRAL HIGH SCHOOL IN.
FIFTY SEVEN HE WAS CALLED SOME
THE MOST ATROCIOUS NAMES WHAT I
WAS TRYING.
TO DESEGREGATE A HIGH SCHOOL.
AND I'VE HEARD ALL OF THOSE
WORDS AND I KNOW WHAT WHICH LIKE --
FOR ME THEY WERE.
SEGREGATION WAS IN SEPARATE
BUILDINGS FOR ME THIS IS WERE WE
SEGREGATE PEOPLE BY LANGUAGE.
LESS DESEGREGATE PEOPLE BY
LANGUAGE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR AND I
CAN AGREE MORE WORDS MATTER.
WE HAVE A MOTION FROM SENATOR
PAM MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM SIX AB FOUR ONE THREE THE
MOTION IS DO YOU PASSED PUBLIC
SAFETY LEYVA AYE LEYVA AYE WILK.
WILK I'D CHANGE CHIANG I'D
RUSSELL GLAZER GLAZER AYE
MCGUIRE PAN PAN HI.
RIGHT THE BILL HAS IN A FULL
SCALE BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THE WITNESSES.
ALL RIGHT I SEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW PLEASE COME ON DOWN.
IT'S YOUR BIRTHDAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER EVERY DAY'S A BIRTHDAY.
EVERY DAY IS IT WORTH A LOOK
LIKE HIM -- NO PLEASE NO
[inaudible]
TODAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR IT THANK
YOU FOR YOUR WARMTH AND KINDNESS
THAT'S ALL THE THIS EXTENDS
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATIVE SESSION AS THAT'S
ALL YEAH.
YEAH [inaudible]
MORE [inaudible]
HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
YOU'RE READY YOU'RE WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN ZERO ONE
THAT HELPS REMOVE THE ARBITRARY
BARRIERS FOR EARNED IT CITY
LEAVES BENEFITS -- BETWEEN
DISTRICTS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
FIVE OH HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES ALSO THIS WEEK HERE IN
SUPPORT.
GREAT JOB ON BREVITY A BIRTHDAY
BOY OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PROCEED.
HELLO MEMBERS A COMMITTEE AND
CHAIR -- MONEY IS RICHARD HANSON
AND YOU TEACH I TAUGHT AT THE
END THE COLLEGE -- I'M RETIRED
NOW BUT I HAVE ENCOUNTERED THIS
ISSUE OVER MANY YEARS -- IT WAS
MY DISTRICT THAT HAD SOME
TROUBLE.
ABOUT FIVE YEARS AGO -- THAT WE
WENT TO FACT WITH WHERE THE
DISTRICT DIDN'T WANT TO ACCEPT --
TRANSFER OF SICKLY FROM A PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBER.
AND AT THAT POINT -- K. TWELVE
AND THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES HAD
THE SAME AD CODE LANGUAGE.
OKAY CALLS A TOTALLY DIFFERENT
WORLD FROM THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IT WAS A YOUNG ONE YEAR
ANDMOST K. TWELVE JOBS YOU KNOW
OUR FULL TIME.
AND YOU OF WOULD TRANSFER
COMPLETELY FROM ONE DISTRICT TO
ANOTHER -- AND WE SHALL AND AND
WITHIN A YEAR YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
TRANSFER YOUR SICK LEAVE AND NOT
STILL IS THE WAY IT IS FOR K..
TWELVE BUT OUR PART TIME FACULTY
OF A HARD TIME WITH THAT --
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE FULL
TIME JOBS AND A TRAVEL AMONG
MANY DISTRICTS OFTEN.
AND FRANKLY NEVER REALLY KNOW
WHEN THEY'RE NO LONGER HIRED IN
A DISTRICT OR WHEN THEY AT WORK
WHEN THEY REALLY COMPLETELY
TERMINATED.
THEY COULD MAYBE NOT AN
pSUDDENLY BE CALLED BACK IF
THERE'S A NEED BECAUSE THEIR
NAME IS STILL IN THE POOL.
SO THE WE WERE HOPING TO GET --
A MORE REASONABLE TIME LIMIT --
WE WERE -- WORKING TOWARD A FIVE
YEAR LIMIT WITH -- ARE
LEGISLATION AT THAT TIME.
AND ENDED UP WITH A THREE AND SO.
THE IDEA ABOUT THAT SORT OF A
TIME LIMIT WAS THAT IF THERE
WERE REEMPLOYMENT RIGHTS ON A
CAMPUS FOR A PART TIME FACULTY
MEMBER.
THAT BY FIVE YEARS THAT THEY
DEFINITELY WOULD HAVE LOST THEM
IF THEY HAD NOT HAD CONTINUOUS
SERVICE. THREE MAYBE THAT'S A
LITTLE DICEY -- BUT THAT'S WHAT
WE ENDED UP WITH.
SINCE THAT TIME.
DISTRICT SEVEN TO REPORTED THIS
LAW.
IN MANY MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
STILL DENYING TRANSFER OF SICK
LEAVE UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES SOME HOLD TO A
HARD A THREE YEAR RULE OTHERS
THINK THAT NO THAT'S REALLY AS
LONG AS YOU'RE STILL STILL
WORKING AT THERE'S NO BREAK IN
SERVICE.
IN THE SYSTEM YOU YOU'RE OKAY SO
WE NEEDED TO JUST CLEAR THIS UP.
OF THE BOTTOM LINE ON THIS IS HE
HAD WITH CAL STIRS IS THAT.
WHEN YOU RETIRE AND EVEN WHILE
YOU'RE STILL WORKING SICKLY Và
SOMETHING YOU EARN IT'S A AND IT
DOES END UP IN RETIREMENT
POTENTIALLY BEING A BENEFIT --
WHERE YOU GET SOME SERVICE
CREDIT FOR YOUR UNUSED SICK
LEAVE?
SO -- REALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PART TIME FACULTY -- WE WANTED
TO PRESS FOR ELIMINATING ANY
TIME LIMIT -- AND I'VE EXPLAINED
WHY THAT IS THEY JUST NEVER KNOW
REALLY WHEN THEY'VE TERMINATED
WITH ANY PARTICULAR DISTRICT.
SO -- THE ONLY THING OTHER THING
I WOULD ADD IS THAT BACK -- WHEN
WE WERE DOING THE EARLIER BILL
AT ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS AGAINST
IT WAS THAT DISTRICTS DON'T KEEP
THESE RECORDS?
BUT IN MY RETIREMENT I WENT TO
ALL THE DISTRICTS I HAD WORKED
IN -- MY EARLIEST ONE I GOT US A
CHANCE TO START TEACHING IN K.
TWELVE AT CRENSHAW HIGH SCHOOL
IN LA UNIFIED ON AN EMERGENCY
CREDENTIAL BECAUSE THEY WERE SO
DESPERATE FOR MATH TEACHERS.
SO THAT'S WHERE I GOT MY START.
THAT WAS BACK IN THE MID
EIGHTIES AND I WENT GOT MY
MASTERS DEGREE IN AND UP AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
BUT THEY HAD MY RECORDS. THIRTY
YEARS AGO THEY WERE ON
MICROFICHE.
BUT THEY HAD THEM.
AND LA UNIFIED GETS A BAD RAP
BUT I'M VERY PROUD TO SPENDING
MY TIME THERE IN K..
TWELVE SO -- THEY DID IT OTHER
DISTRICTS CAN DO IT AND I REALLY
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
IT'S GOING TO BE GREAT FOR OUR
PART TIME FACULTY IN THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN WITH THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
HOW IN IN NINETY AND TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN WE DID SPONSOR
AB TWO TWO NINE FIVE WHICH
EXTENDED AS RICH SAID THE ONE
YEAR TO THREE YEARS?
WE FOUND THAT'S NOT SUFFICIENT.
IT'S PART A PART TIME FACULTY
ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
BY THIS -- THEY MAKE UP MOST OF
OUR FACULTY.
AND FOR THAT REASON WE'RE SPROUT
TO SPONSOR THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ADDITIONAL
WHAT MRS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JENNIFER BAKER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION PLEASED TO SUPPORT
THIS ISSUE WHICH IMPACTS ALL OR
PART TIME FACULTY MEMBERS.
MORNING BRIAN HOW WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WERE A STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
DAVE ALL RATS REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RETIRED TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SANDRA BOROUGH ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARIO GUERRERO ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA FACULTY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY WITH OTHER
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS THE BILL HAS
BEEN MOVED WOULD YOU LIKE T
CLOSE ASSEMBLY MEMBER I JUST
WANT TO AGAIN THANK ALL OF YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
AND AND THAT MAY I MISTER HANSON
WHEN HE WAS THE LEAD FOR A FACT
ASSOCIATION AND OVER AT THE END
OF FOOT.
HILL A COLLEGE AND AGAIN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
ACCOMMODATION YOU'RE VERY
WELCOME.
AND THE BILL'S BEEN MOVED BY
SENATOR CHIANG MA'AM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB SEVEN A SIX TO
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILK WILK I CHIANG
CHIANG I'D LASSELL GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN PAN HI.
THE BILL HAS A FULL TO GET OUT
BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT ON CALL.
HAVE A GOOD REST YOUR BIRTHDAY
DAY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
ALL RIGHT ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MORNING AND CHECK
PROCEED WHATEVER YOU'RE READY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER I'M READY LET'S
DO THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT AB ELEVEN
FIFTY TODAY.
AS YOU OF ALL CERTAINLY NO
EXPERIENCE TO COME HERE -- IN
ORDER QUALIFY I TO GET ON THE
BALLOT AS A STATE SENATOR YOU
HAD TO PROVIDE EITHER A FILING
FEE OR NUMBER OF SIGNATURES --
IN LIEU THIS IS NOT THE CASE FOR
THE SAN DIEGO IN THE COURSE NOT
CLEAR MARKET COMMITTEE CALLS
DISTRICT BOARDS -- AB ELEVEN
FIFTY WOULD INSTITUTE THAT
REQUIREMENT OF AT LEAST ONE
HUNDRED SIGNATURES IN ORDER
SUPPORT THE CANDIDACY OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WILLING TO SERVE OUR
INTEREST IN SERVING ON THAT
BOARD.
COLLECTING THE SIGNATURES IS A
COMMON SENSE AND DEMOCRATIC WAY
TO DEMONSTRATE COMMUNITY SUPPORT
AND TO ENSURE THE KIDS RUNNING
FOR THESE POSITIONS HAVE SOME
LEVEL OF BACK IN THEIR DISTRICTS
THEY SEEK TO REPRESENT.
A WITH ME TODAY'S BRIAN HOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS FEDERATION.
THE USE OF A MEMBER MISTER HALL
PLEASE PROCEED MANAGER.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE BRIAN
HOW THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS.
THIS BILL WILL ALSO HELP ENSURE
THAT THE MOST COMMITTED AND
QUALIFIED CANDIDATES WOULD RUN
FOR THE SEATS THAT THEY ARE
TRYING TO OUT AND OUT WHEN --
THIS BILL IS ALSO SUPPORTED BY
THE SAN DIEGO AND GROSSMONT
CUYAMACA COMMITTEE COLLEGE
DISTRICTS IN ADDITION TO SEVERAL
OF OUR LOCALS -- I ACTUALLY I
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ARE THERE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS YES.
THANK YOU FOR AND WILK.
SO I HAVE NINE HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND CONSTITUENTS ID GET
FORTY SIGNATURES SO WHAT WHY IT
WHY A HUNDRED I'D SAID.
WE'VE WHERE WERE BASICALLY
TRYING TO MIRROR WHAT IS
CURRENTLY REQUIRED AT THE SAN
DIEGO COUNTY COD K. TWELVE
DISTRICT.
THE K. TWELVE DISTRICT THERE ARE
HARD TO GET A HUNDRED YES
MATCHES THE OVERLAPPING SCHOOL.
ARE YOU IN DISTRICTS NOW I
BECAUSE I DON'T KNOW BUT I MISS
ME ARE YOU GUYS IN YOU'RE NOT AT
LARGE ANYMORE.
DISTRICTS BETWEEN HOUSING AS
THEY ARE BY DISTRICT YES I
DISTRICT.
OKAY HI.
I I I UNDERSTAND BECAUSE WHEN
IT'S TOO EASY TO FILE THEN YOU
GET PEOPLE WHO ARE THERE TO JUST
GRAB ATTENTION OR WHATEVER.
HUNDRED AND I'M I'M I'M
GRAPPLING WITH THAT'LL SEE WHAT
ID.
SEE I MEAN JUST.
WE HAVE A TWO FORTY A HUNDRED I
DON'T KNOW BUT IT AND SO THAT IS
THE STANDARD THE K. TWELVE YES
AT THE CURRENTLY AT THE US AND
WHY OKAY TOYS RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WILK ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A CAFFEINE I DESPERATELY
NEED.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR PAN
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ITEM TWENTY FIVE AB ELEVEN FIFTY
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
ELECTIONS AND CONSTITUTIONAL
AMENDMENTS LEYVA.
LEYVA I WILL HI WILK I CHIANG.
CHIANG I'D RUSSELL.
GLAZERS GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE PAN
PAN AYE.
VERY GOOD THE BILL HAS ENOUGH
WILL SEE APPLE WILL EVEN ON CALL.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
ALBRIGHT.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN THERE YOU
ARE COME ON DOWN [inaudible]
ON THAT.
GOOD MORNING.
MORNING THEN SIR PLEASE PROCEED
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THANK YOU
VERY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES HER SENATORS I SHOULD
SAY SCHOOL BASED HEALTH SERVICES
PLAY A KEY ROLE IN ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS ARE SAFE AND
READY TO LEARN.
SINCE THE EARLY NINETEEN
NINETIES K<c.cyan> THROUGH TWELVE</c>
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE REIMBURSEMENT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FOR DIRECT
HEALTH SERVICES PROVIDED AT
SCHOOL SITES.
THROUGH SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
PROGRAMS INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE
THE LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY
MEDI CAL BILLING OPTION PROGRAM.
DUE TO A RECENT FEDERAL CHANGE
THE ELLIE A BILLING OPTION
PROGRAM THAT USED TO BE ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR SPECIAL EDUCATION
STUDENTS WILL BE OPEN TO ALL
MEDI CAL ELIGIBLE STUDENTS.
THIS CHANGE WOULD ALLOW FOR MANY
MORE ELIGIBLE STUDENTS TO
RECEIVE HEALTH SERVICES AT
SCHOOL INCLUDING HEALTH
EVALUATIONS PHYSICIAN SERVICES
AND MENTAL HEALTH AND COUNSELING
SERVICES.
WHEN POORLY TREATED HEALTH AND
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS CAN
HAVE A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON
SCHOOL ATTENDANCE BEHAVIOR AND
ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT?
IN CALIFORNIA THERE IS NO
INSTITUTIONALIZE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WHICH OVERSEES
MEDI CAL.
AND THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO COORDINATE VARIOUS
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
DELIVERED THROUGH SCHOOLS.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY TO ESTABLISH
AN OFFICE OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
PROGRAMS WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION. FOR THE
PURPOSES OF PROVIDING TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE FOR HEALTH RELATED
PROGRAMS ADVISING ON ISSUES
RELATED TO THE DELIVERY OF
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH AND BE IF
YOU'RE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
WITH THE UPCOMING EXPANSION OF
ELIGIBILITY TO RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
SERVICES THERE IS AN OPPORTUNITY
FOR AN OFFICE A SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH PROGRAMS. TO PLAY A VITAL
ROLE IN ASSISTING SCHOOLS THAT
WISH TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS TO DRAW DOWN FEDERAL
FUNDS.
INSURING THAT CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS MAY CONTINUE TO
RECEIVING HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES AT SCHOOL SITES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE
ON A. B. THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO AND
WITH ME TODAY.
IS BARBER CHRONIC -- FROM THE
SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND TONI TRIGGER --
FROM THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER PLEASE
PERCENT WHEN YOU'RE READY
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO MY NAME IS
BARBARA CHRONIC AND I AM THE
FORMER DIRECTOR OF STUDENT
SUPPORT AND HEALTH SERVICES.
AND SACRAMENTO CITY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT I AM CURRENTLY
ON THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH ALLIANCE.
AND TEACHERS FOR HEALTHY KIDS
BOTH ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF A. B..
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ESTABLISH AN OFFICE OF
SCHOOL BASED HEALTH PROGRAMS.
AS SOMEONE WHO WORKED IN SCHOOLS
TO BRING TWO SILOS.
HEALTH AND EDUCATION TOGETHER TO
MEET THE NEEDS OF STUDENTS I CAN
TELL YOU HOW DIFFICULT THE WORK
IS.
SCHOOLS ARE NATURALLY SET UP. TO
BE HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
BILL HEALTH CARE FUNDING STREAMS.
AND OUR HEALTH CARE SYSTEM.
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND HOW OUR
SCHOOLS ARE OFTEN AT THE FRONT
LINES FOR ENROLLING KIDS AND
HEALTH COVERAGE AND IDENTIFYING
STUDENTS WITH SIGNIFICANT HEALTH
AND MENTAL HEALTH CHALLENGES.
IN MANY RESPECTS THEY DON'T
SPEAK THE SAME LANGUAGE.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO WOULD ADD
INFRASTRUCTURE AND CAPACITY AT
C. D. E. TO FORGE A STRONGER
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
IN ORDER TO COLLABORATE AND
BRING THESE TWO SILOS TOGETHER.
HISTORICALLY THIS WORK HAS BEEN
THE RESPONIBILITY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES WITHOUT A FORMAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION.
SCHOOLS WANT AND NEED MORE
SUPPORT FROM C. D. AS THEY
ADDRESS THE HEALTH AND MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS
PARTICULARLY WHEN IT COMES TO
NAVIGATING THE SCHOOL MEDICAID
PROGRAMS.
THEY NEED TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
WITH CD IS UNDERSTANDING OF THE
DISTRICTS THEY CAN MORE DIRECTLY
ASSIST AND TRAIN DISTRICTS TO
CREATE BETTER SYSTEMS FOR
CLAIMING REIMBURSEMENT AND
ULTIMATELY FUNDING SERVICES FOR
STUDENTS.
WE KNOW THAT THE FROM THE DATA
THAT THERE IS A DIRECT
CORRELATION BETWEEN HEALTH AND
POSITIVE EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
THIS IS THE RIGHT TIME TO
CAPITALIZE ON OPPORTUNITIES AND
STRENGTHEN CD EASE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO SUPPORT SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME AND
ATTENTION I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU PLEASE
PROCEED MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME'S TONY TO
KERO AND THEY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA.
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION ONE OF THE
CO SPONSORS OF A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO THE SERGEANTS HAVE
DISTRIBUTED AN ABBREVIATED COPY
OF THE MARCH FOURTEENTH.
TWENTY NINETEEN JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEES
EXAMINATION OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES THE AUDIT
POINTS OUT CALIFORNIA RANKS
FORTIETH IN THE COUNTRY.
AND IS CONSISTENTLY BELOW 50%
FOR UTILIZATION RATES A
PREVENTIVE SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN AND MEDI CAL.
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS AND PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FUNDS WERE IDENTIFIED. FOR
REPAYMENT THIS YEAR TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FROM SCHOOL
DISTRICTS.
HAD DH CS PROVIDED MORE ADEQUATE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO SCHOOLS
AND PROTESTED THE AUDIT FINDINGS
SCHOOLS WOULD HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS THIS YEAR.
A MUCH NEEDED MONEY TO SUPPORT
OUR STUDENTS.
LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
THIRTEEN AB THIRTY ONE NINETY
TWO WHAT TRAFFIC IS REFERENCED
IN YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
SCHOOLS REQUIRE CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY IN THE
ADMINISTRATION OF THE PROGRAM TO
APPROPRIATELY BILL FOR THE
HEALTH SERVICES THEY PROVIDE.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE HAD
TROUBLE RECEIVING THAT
APPROPRIATE GUIDANCE FROM DH CS
AND SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
SEIZE PARTICIPATING IN THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE OF THESE
PROBLEMS. TO RUN SMOOTHLY AND
MAX MY FUNDING ELIGIBILITY
SCHOOLS REQUIRE SUPPORT FROM
STATE AGENCIES RESPONSIBLE FOR
BOTH HEALTH.
AND EDUCATION PROGRAMS
CALIFORNIA HAS NO
INSTITUTIONALIZE PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN THE TWO IN THIS CASE DH
CS AND CD TO COORDINATE HEALTH
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES DELIVERED
THROUGH SCHOOLS.
CTA BELIEVES THAT AB THIRTY
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO ESTABLISHING
AN OFFICE OF SCHOOL BASED HEALTH
WILL ASSIST SCHOOLS IN PROVIDING
THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
NOT NOW AVAILABLE FROM DH CS THE
EXPANSION OF HEALTH CARE'S
HEALTH SERVICES LATER THEIR
TEACHER WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS
PROMOTE HEALTHIER OUTCOMES.
EDITRICE BEHAVIORAL ISSUES AND
KEATING STUDENTS FROM SUCCESS
WHICH IN TURN WILL HELP STUDENTS
AND FAMILIES FEEL SAFE INCREASE
STUDENT ENGAGEMENT AND STUDENT
SUCCESS.
WE URGE OUR AYE VOTE ON A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
ERIC OFTEN OF THE OF THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL BOARDS
ASSOCIATION VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT
NURTURE AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THEN A GARCIA WITH TEACHERS FOR
HEALTHY KIDS OF SUPPORT.
ANITA AVERAGE CATIONADVOCATE
CALIFORNIA STATE PTA IS PART.
ALEXANDRABUT AS NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
FREE TO WALLACE WITH THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA BALL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
PSYCHOLOGISTS AND SUPPORT.
MEDIA ONE REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL NURSES WE ALSO
CO SPONSORS OF THIS BILL.
THAT STRESS WRONGLY ENOUGH THE
NEED FOR THIS ARM COLLABORATIVE
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE FRONT
OF IT AND DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES.
WE ASKED WE I'VE OF GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ON RAP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE INTO THE REGION
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL COUNSELORS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
BIG ROAMING OVER HALF OF THE
HUMBLE COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION AND THE SANTA CLARA
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION BOTH
IN SUPPORT.
OLDER SHALLOW WOULD LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBERS CONNIE DELGADO ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF AMENDED
POSITION WE'D LIKE TO SEE SOME
COORDINATION WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS AND
THE BILLING IN CLEANING AND THE
ISSUES THAT YOU MENTION.
OF TO PROVIDE EXPERTISE IN
TREATING THESE PATIENTS AND AND
THESE STUDENTS WHO DESPERATELY
WILL BE SERVICES THANK YOU.
MICHAEL SAYS THERE ON BEHALF OF
THE KERN COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT
OF SCHOOLS OFFICE WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
THERE ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
CNN WILL BRING IT BACK TO RAISE
YOUR HAND YEAH I DR YEAH ARE YOU
IN OPPOSITION.
WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE DR.
I FIRST OF ALL THANK YOU NUMBER
BERMAN -- FOR BRING THIS BILL
FOR AND ALSO SOME MERIT DONALD --
AND ALSO -- I SHOULD MENTION I
WAS PREVIOUSLY -- THE MEDICAL
CONSULT FOR SEXY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU
AGAIN.
WE WORK TOGETHER ON MANY OF
THESE ISSUES AND THAT AND THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT -- I'VE WORKED
ON QUITE A BIT HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE -- WHEN I CHAIRED
THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH COMMITTEE --
I ACTUALLY -- COMPELLED DTS TO
ATTEND THE MEETING WITH
EDUCATION.
LEAVE THAT.
THERE WAS SOME RESISTANCE AND
THAT WAS THE FIRST TIME THE THE
PART HEALTH KERR'S CARE SERVICES
HAD STAFF MEETING WITH.
FOLKS FROM -- DEPARTMENT OF FROM
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE FROM
EDUCATION INTERESTING ENOUGH --
CURLEWS THAN CHAIR OF CENTER
LOSE CHAIR OF THIS COMMITTEE --
HER STAFF SAID THIS THE FIRST
TIME WE CAN GET THEM TO ACTUALLY
MEET WITH US.
WE WERE WE'VE BEEN TRYING FOR
YEARS AND IS THE FIRST TIME --
SO.
THE THIS IS BEEN A LONG STANDING
ISSUE HERE IN CALIFORNIA I
APPRECIATE YOU SHARING THE
RESULTS OF THE AUDIT BUT I THINK
MORE IMPORTANTLY I THINK.
AND I DON'T REMEMBER EXACTLY
NUMBER WHAT BUT WE'RE LIKE FORTY
FIFTH THERE FORTY SIX AND THE
ACTUAL RATE OF DRAWING DOWN.
FUNDS FOR OUR SCHOOL BASED
HEALTH THROUGH OUR MEDI CAL
PROGRAM.
SO IF THE POINT I I DO HAVE TO
ASK A QUESTION ABOUT THIS BILLS
I SEE THERE'S ONE I PERCEIVED-WEAKNESS AND ABOVE I THINK WE
CAN TRY TO FIX THAT AND SO. TO
WHAT DEGREE IS D. EIGHT C. S. X.
SO I UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU'RE
DOING IS ESTABLISHING A GROUP N.
C. E. AND THAT'S GONNA BE
IMPORTANT TO WORK WITH THE
VARIOUS ELLIE ETS AND SO FORTH --
BUT OF COURSE WE TALK ABOUT MEDI
CAL YOU DTS HAS TO BE INVOLVED
BECAUSE IT IS THE AGENCY THE
INTERFACES WITH ON THE FEDERAL
LEVEL CMS THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE MEDICAID SERVICES WHICH
AND THAT'S WHERE WE GOT TO ALL
THE TROUBLE TO RULES AND AND THE
CLEANING AND ALL.
THIS AND I BELIEVE ME I WAS
INVOLVED WITH THAT AND I WAS
TRYING TO GET OUR FEDERAL FOLKS
WITH CENTER FEINSTEIN IT.
DOES IT -- THE WHOLE ISSUES SO.
WHAT IS THE ROLE OF DH CS IN
RELATION TO THIS OFFICE OR WE
COMPELLING DTS TO PARTICIPATE
WITH THIS OFFICE IN THIS BILL?
I THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION AND
AND YOUR PRACTICES START MAKING
WONDER IF WE HAVE THE WRONG
AUTHOR FOR THIS BILL -- AND THEN
AND YOU AND SAYS.
NOW IF YOU WANTED TO WE CAN WORK
TOGETHER ON THIS LET'S LET'S
LET'S DEFINITELY WORK TOGETHER I
I DON'T RECALL TO WHAT EXTENT
WITH TO COMPEL THEM.
OR OR TO WHAT EXTENT --
VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE -- AND
AND PROVIDE -- YOU KNOW THEIR
THEIR GUIDANCE AND EXPERTISE SO
LET ME GET BACK TO YOU OKAY LET
ME THAT REALLY NICE THAT THIS
WAY I UNDERSTAND THIS BILL IF IT
PASSES THIS COMMITTEE GOES THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE WHICH I CHAIR.
THERE WE GO IT'S PERFECT TIMING --
WE IF AND LESS THE CHAIR OF THIS
COMMITTEE HAS ANY OBJECTION OR
THE AUTHORS HAVE OBJECTIONS I
HOPE THAT -- WE MIGHT CONSIDER
THINKING ABOUT.
SOME ADDITIONS TO THE BELL THAT
WOULD MAKE THE EIGHT CS HALF TO
WORK WITH THIS OFFICE -- AND
COMMUNICATE BECAUSE OTHERWISE
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT YOU STILL
HAVE THE ORIGINAL PROBLEM RIGHT
OKAY AND IF THE ATS DOES NOT
ENGAGE.
AND DOES NOT BY THE WAY FIGHT.
FOR OUR SCHOOLS WITH CMS YEAH
BUT THE ONLY.
QUOTE PASSED DOWN THE RULES AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO MAKE PROGRESS
YEAH AND SO.
I JUST WANT TO PUT THAT OUT
THERE BE SURE WE DON'T HAVE ANY
PROBLEMS AT THAT BUT I HOPE THAT
YOU'RE OPEN.
TO SOME ADDITIONAL I'M NOT GONNA
TRY TO MANY THING HERE BUT HER --
SOME IDEAS ABOUT.
BECAUSE DETAILS HAS TO BE PART
OF THIS PROCESS WITHOUT IT WE
CAN HAVE A SEPARATE OFFICE I
THINK WILL HELP.
ME HELP COMMUNICATIONS DTS BUT
UNLESS THE PART HEALTHCARE
SERVICES WHICH IS THE AGENCY
CHARGED WITH RYAN MEDI CAL
PROGRAM YEAH ISN'T ALSO PART OF
THIS.
TEAM WHEN I COMMIT KIND OF
PRIVACY TOTALLY AGREE.
OKAY YEAH LET'S LET'S DON'T HAVE
A CONVERSATION BEFORE COMES TO
IF IT GETS OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
IT DOES.
NOT PRESUME ANYTHING BUT I WILL
MOVE THE BILL TO HELP TRY TO
MOVE OUT OF THE BILL AT
APPROPRIATE TIMES THE YOU DON'T
HAVE BEEN THANK YOU SENATOR PAN --
WE WE DON'T HAVE ANY AMENDMENTS
TO THE BILL WE HERE AT SENATE
AND LIKE IT THE WAY IT IS BUT I
WOULD CAN STATE THAT THE TWO OF
YOU CAN TALK AND WHEN IT GETS TO
YOUR COMMITTEE YOU CAN OFFER
AMENDMENTS ISSUES.
CENTER CHIANG THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I NOTICED
THAT THERE IS OPPOSITION FROM
CALIFORNIA RIGHT TO LIFE
COMMITTEE AND I I HAVEN'T HEARD
AS TO WHAT THE OPPOSITION IS.
I FOUND OUT ABOUT THAT FIVE
MINUTES AGO -- SO I'M NOT SURE.
EITHER -- I DON'T KNOW IF I HAVE
AN OPPOSITION LETTER.
WE THOUGHT MAYBE THEY COME AND
EXPRESS THEIR CONCERNS.
WE HAVE A LETTER.
TRYING TO FIND WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO FIND INFORMATION THIS MORNING.
OKAY I FOUND IT IS CONCERNED
ABOUT ANOTHER OFFICE BEING
CREATED AND ANOTHER MANDATE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION.
SO I'M GONNA LAY OFF TODAY'S
BECAUSE I I NEED MORE
INFORMATION BUT I MIGHT CHANGE
MY VOTE ON THE FLOOR THE SENATE.
THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG MEMBERS
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK -- I
APPRECIATE THE THE CONVERSATION
AND AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THE
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
PANTS BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
I AM TWENTY EIGHT AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TO THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO HELP LEYVA.
LEYVA AYE WILKWILK I CHIANG TO
WRESTLE.
GLAZER.
GLAZER AYE MCGUIRE HAN.
WELL YOU WORKING.
GIVEN EFFORTS TO GET OUT WHAT
WILL EVEN ON CALL THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU LADIES
[inaudible]
GREAT JOB [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK.
YOU FOR THE BEGINNING
[inaudible]
YEAH.
WHY ARE TAXI I WALK INTO
[inaudible]
YEAH
WHICH WILL LEAVE THAT BILL
I'M CALL
.
YEAH.
OKAY [inaudible]
RIGHT
.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
LIKE THAT.
YEAH THAT'S RIGHT OKAY ALL RIGHT
HERE WE GO.
WE'RE GONNA START WITH THE ITEM
SIX AB FOR THIRTEEN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
ITEM SIX EIGHTY FOUR THIRTY FOUR
THIRTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO PUBLIC SAFETY WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FIVE
ZERO ASAL COMMON CHOIR.
MCGUIRE.
THANK YOU WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE
THE WHOLE ON FAST.
THE BILL IS OUT SIX ZERO MOVING
ON THE FILE ITEM SEVEN AB FIVE
FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ITEM SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
FOURTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE FLOOR WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE.
THAT BILLS SEVEN ZERO MOVING ON
TO FILE ITEM -- TEN A. B. FIVE
NINETY FIVE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM TEN A. B.
FIVE NINETY FIVE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO PUBLIC SAFETY WITH
THAT YOU'RE VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE I'D THAT BILLS OUT.
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM -- TWENTY
TWELVE ITEM TWELVE AB SIX NINETY
FIVE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I VICE CHAIR VOTING I SIX
ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE BILLS OUT SEVEN ZERO
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE ALLEN -- FOURTEEN I
WITH -- ITEM FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN A SIX THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I'VE VICE CHAIR
VOTING I FIVE ZERO DOCILE
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE AYE THE BILL IS OUT.
SIX ZERO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY THREE ITEM TWENTY THREE
A. B. TEN NINETY THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE CHAIR
VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI THE BILL OUT.
SEVEN ZERO FILE ITEM.
TWENTY FIVE I AM TWENTY FIVE AB
ELEVEN FIFTY THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I BY SURE
VOTING I FIVE ZERO WOULD I STILL
MCGUIRE.
MCGUIRE HI BUT BILLS OUT.
SIX ZERO FILE ITEM TWENTY EIGHT
ITEM TWENTY EIGHT A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY TO THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED TO HELP WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I'VE I SURE VOTING I FOUR
ZERO CHIANG.
WHO WRESTLE MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE?
BILLS OUT.
FIVE ZERO AND LAST BUT NOT LEAST
FILE ITEM TWENTY NINE I ITEM
TWENTY NINE A. B. FIFTEEN NO FOR
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ADVISED HER NOT VOTING
FOR ZERO WILK.
CHIANG MCGUIRE MCGUIRE AYE AND
THAT FILLS OUT FIVE ZERO AS WELL.
THANK YOU SENATOR MCGUIRE -- WE
HAVE YOUR CONSENT HELD A FOR YOU
SO SORRY I'M CONSENT CALENDAR.
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I VICE
CHAIR VOTING I SIX ZERO MCGUIRE
MCGUIRE AYE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GO BACK AND
HAVE FUN THANK YOU EVERYONE WE
ARE ADJOURNED